[Laughter]
I'm just thinking that you're 29 if
you're in a relationship like do you
want kids yes um do you don't have any
kids so you know if you're single by 30
your chance of having a child drops
below 50 so you're actually more likely
you're to not have a kid than have one
and by 34 your chance of having like any
kids at all like geriatric pregnancy
working is like nothing it's like yeah I
see it's pretty scary so it's like
though
I said I know the good eyes
because I'm assuming you're picky right
uh to find like picky like I think I
have my standards I don't think I ask
for anything too crazy I just want a guy
that's like serious about me has pure
intentions for me and will be loyal well
I'm just thinking because you've been
dating since what 18 yeah 20 yeah right
20 okay so like I'm just thinking of
nine years if none of the guys that
approached you you like enough to marry
like you're probably picky oh right
and this is just me like usually that
women that are single over the age like
they're 25. it's not an insult you know
no no no I think to be honest I'm a
Christian and I think that that makes
things a bit harder for me because
there's certain things that I'm like
that I want to do to please God or
there's some some views that I have that
are more like biblical than like the
world and I think that now I used to
date guys that were non-christians but
the things that I was passionate about
the values that I had they didn't share
those same values and I want to be with
someone that shares those same values as
me and has the same world for you as me
so now that's kind of it's just him
being a Christian no I mean he has to be
a Christian of course but there's just
certain things that like I've realized
are my deal breakers like why are you
one of the waiting until marriage type I
mean yeah I'm not I'm not perfect but
that's definitely a desire it's a desire
to want to wait until marriage yeah okay
but you're I'm assuming 29 I'm not a
virgin I'm not a virgin but nobody's
waiting for it I mean I mean yeah that's
the type of world that we're living in
it's definitely a desire I'm not saying
it won't happen but it's a desire and I
would like to stick to that because I
guess in my head I'm like okay so if
you're 29 you know that by now now you
know at least that if you're single by
next year you're most likely not going
to have a kid
and that by 34 your chance of having a
kid is basically nothing like
biologically so I'm just thinking if you
get into a relationship with a guy that
you like which I'm assuming is very hard
to find a guy that meets all your
criteria because I mean me too it's not
you're not not just you because I'm
thinking like if you get to that point
it's kind of like your last
chance in a way and then you and then
you leave it over what a message
it's like I would think in the grand
scheme of things it would be more
important to have a family to you
especially you know they say like be
fruitful and multiply in the Bible yeah
but I think for me it's also very
important to be in a situation that is
healthy and I would rather be single
than be in a relationship where I'm not
valued or where I'm being disrespected
or where the duties emotionally or
sexually cheating yeah sometimes I just
Church like leaves women single and I
think it's really sad because I think
sometimes they tell women like we have
to have these crazy high standards yeah
yeah I think that the church that's not
the message you know that's not that
crazy but I think the church does need
to do a better job with teaching young
Christians like how to date like I go to
an amazing church and it's I'm learning
now like through I go to the tab London
and my pastor is is amazing and he just
recently done a sermon on dating and
like how to date you know you know for
marriage with the intention of marriage
and it was very healthy and very
informative would would you submit to
your husband for everything
but the thing is like with me choosing a
husband I'm gonna choose somebody that I
respect I'm going to choose somebody
that loves God and for me submission is
about if he submitted submitting to
Christ I'm low-key submitting to Christ
if I'm submitting to my husband so then
why did you say no but it's like to me
submitting I think I need to learn about
that more I'm definitely my own woman
but I think it depends in like in what
degree like in what situation do you
follow the Bible
I try well no it just it confuses me
when like then I become one in the Bible
they say the same thing you have to
submit in the Bible
I think it just confuses me like when
you say you want a Christian man but you
don't want to live in a Christian way so
like why would a man that's super
Christian want to be with you if you
don't want to live in a Christian way
which is biblical but what do you mean
by not living in a Christian way so in
the Bible says you have to submit to
your husband and when I asked you you
said no yeah but then and but this is
what I'm saying I think in certain
situations I think and how can I wear
this in certain situations of course if
the decision that my husband is making
makes sense and that's fine
yeah I don't really know how to just to
explain the thoughts that I'm having
right now you want to submit when you
feel like it
yes
but then the Bible also the thing is the
Bible does instruct women with like how
to act in marriage but then the Bible
also instructs men with how to treat
their wives as well and so like the
Bible says to women like respect your
husbands and husbands love your wives
and so I feel like yeah but how are we
supposed to get a Christian guy if we
can't start with what we have to do yeah
folks you know like yes I'm just I'm
just you know because you want to start
a family yeah so I'm just wondering how
this should work out go ahead is it an
issue of knowing so you said about the
whole decision thing
um which logically makes sense so like
if he's saying something and you don't
I'm just guessing right if he says
something and you don't know why is your
point you want to know why and if it
makes sense to you then you agree and
that's your version of submitting
yeah I think and that's the thing my
thing is I think that a marriage there's
going to be a lot of like complexities
and like a lot of different situations
that we're going to face in marriage
it's going to be a learning curve it's
going to be like a journey and I think
that also with whatever the Bible does
say the Bible also teaches about like
sanctification and about like a journey
of becoming more like a Christ so I'm
not saying that I'm perfect but I'm
saying hopefully me and my husband will
get to a point where you know we're on
the same page and I think yeah you don't
believe like going with the flow no no
no don't say no because going with the
flow could be the best thing the reason
why I say going with the flow you could
be dating you could be on Tinder
whatever and someone could say what are
you looking for right and I could say
for me as a 33 year old I want a child I
want a child but I don't have a if God
blesses me with a child I get blessed
with a child I'm not religious in any
way shape or form but I believe in in An
Almighty my thing right now when I meet
a girl or a guy and they say like what
you're looking for to say look like my
portfolio would say like I want kids
soon blah blah blah but I'll just say
look I'm just here going for the flow
but I'm looking for a a serious
individual and I would elaborate on that
situation but like when I say I'm going
with the flow doesn't mean I want to
marry you or date you I just want to
chill with you and see where things go
so there is no expectations on either
side you know what I mean it's just
about getting to know the person getting
to know the person but I feel like if
you're with the whole Christian thing
um hats off to you
um
I feel like for guys it can be a bit
intimidating and we don't know where to
start and we're like oh okay you know
what I mean baby you say like Glenn
others just super chat says there's no
exception to submission in the Bible
where it says to only submit to your
husband when you want to it says for
everything because you gotta choose a
man that you trust to lead right and
then you've got to listen to it you've
got to submit to because it's as simple
as that sometimes you can ask like at
the end of the day if you really are
submitting to your husband you're
trusting that they know what they're
doing they're handling things so any
decision they make you shouldn't even be
questioning it anyway because you should
trust them enough to know that they've
already fought that through so you don't
have to so by asking questions you're
kind of creating problems for him for
having to explain it all through to you
and then also you're potentially causing
another problem by then putting up a
barrier if you don't agree with
something that he's done like to me I
would rather leave him with it he says
we're doing something fine I trust him
enough that he knows what he's doing and
he's doing that for our best interest
look at team sports here let's say
imagine Alex Ferguson's your manager and
then he's like cool this player is going
to win us the champions league and we're
like actually and you got this one
brother that's always always uh nah I'm
the manager yeah I'm here to do a job
trust I'm gonna lead and we'll go if you
find a man that keeps leading you into
the into the darkness then that's not
the man for you I guess in it but you
gotta you gotta be on that journey and
actually accept that call I've chosen
this person I just thought of a question
do you think it it is unbiblical if
women don't have children
the God says to be fruitful and multiply
right and right now women are 100 in
control of who's born so like sex and
reproduction because we're the only ones
that can have a choice in abortion
um and the way the laws are set up like
we're 100 in control so is it unbiblical
if women don't have kids a woman should
be in full control is her buddy and what
she wants to no I'm not I'm not asking a
question like okay
um I can gossip and I'm in full control
if I want to gossip or not but it's
unbiblical of me to gossip I think
anyways I think if a woman can have kids
she should have kids
so yeah you're right and also for people
who are believers Christians it is still
their responsibility to go and preach
the word and and do anything to do see
this is this is where I come because I
was going to come to your point because
I'm also a Christian right so I I
believe in all the same passages
like not so for the first because I have
two things for the first thing was to
your point about submission
now as a follow-up question when we say
submit to God does that mean like what
does that mean because then we have to
think about the words that we're using
because we use those words in
Christianity already right let me say we
need to submit to Jesus we submit submit
to God submit to the word of Christ
right
that same submission and the
understanding of what it means to submit
to Christ in that same vein obviously
it's not the same because the person
you're submitted to isn't Jesus I'm not
trying to equate them but it's this very
similar vein of like you wouldn't like
like you like you said you wouldn't
question what's coming next if you were
100 submissive now understanding who to
be submissive to is very very difficult
because there are a lot of Snakes in the
Grass there's a lot of people who show
one thing show one hand and actually are
another like like we were saying before
but the actual Act of to say I would
only submit in a certain in a certain
situation which is not what you said but
it's like what it sounds like sounds
like right don't you think it's I don't
think it's that difficult to be honest
what do you mean like I don't think it's
like we kind of like as women like we
act like there's so many men that are
cheating and doing all this stuff but
most men can't do that yeah it's true
like I think there's a lot of average
guys like as women we can date that
wouldn't actually I don't think it's
that crazy it's it's not but what I'm
saying is in the sense of like I'm I'm
taking it back to the biblical the
biblical sense of submission and the
submission that God has told us to do to
his people and for for him and his son
Jesus right so we understand as
Christians what submission is
but when it comes to submission user
submission to man it becomes slightly
different to Jesus yeah I think there's
just been a breakdown in trust but yeah
right now that's what I'm saying you
know what I mean so with like women
don't really trust families
you know our Glenn says no it's not
unbiblical because there are women who
are born that don't have the ability to
have kids okay
um would you have an issue submitting to
your boss
for you someone asked me
um
yes there has been times with past
managers where I think that they're not
always making the right decision okay
and so but I think that I do believe in
just creating that space that respectful
safe environment where I can voice my
opinions they can voice theirs and then
we can just have that conversation
because I think that even if you're my
boss it doesn't mean that like you can't
take on good advice or like do things in
a different way so I think I think I can
submit but I believe in being vocal do
you know how tiring that is as a boss
though
oh my gosh if I told my editor edit the
video this way and every single time I
gave him something he's telling me the
way he wants to do it do you know how
annoying that is no I mean it's not it's
not okay you've got nothing done like
it's not a case where every five seconds
I've got a problem but there's just been
a couple of situations in the past I
believe in being vocal I believe in
being vocal I believe in creating that
safe space to have a conversation with
the person once they've got all of the
information then they can make their
decision
um away glances or where to look at
submission is like this I will always
respect and submit to the president even
if I don't like him I am submitting to
the position that he holds uh Danny said
this is forget Pearl the summer AC funds
yeah yeah we do need summer we need AC
in here oh [__] does that make sense to
you though what he said yeah that's very
powerful yeah
um no I I don't think you're like I
think a lot of times in the church they
don't really talk about submission it's
odd like not not in the true sense they
do in the sense of like submitting to a
higher being and it's been to like the
will of God and the will of the the
Bible itself but like interpersonal
submission not too much they mention it
it gets mentioned but it doesn't get
like delved into it like great detail
outside of like God man submit to him
and that one gets fleshed out more than
man to man if that makes sense
yeah I think I think there's a lot of
selective politicking with when it comes
to religion so 100 and I think
everyone's out here they're they're
beating they're enjoying life they're
drinking they're doing the thing and
then it's traditional in a sense when
you need to do this so listen later
when it suits you yeah
blessing no I'm just gonna hit the point
and say that they don't mention it
because the majority of uh churchgoers
are now women and their catering to
women so if they're pre-submission
you're not going to get much of an
audience really damn there you go the
church has been verbally feminized wow
I mean why do you think they have like
gay flags in the church now no yeah
[Music]
no no no
but is that to do with remember it's got
to do with fitting in like the whole
lgbtq plus I can't remember the whole
name yeah
um it's like a it's like a common thing
now it's like it's a big thing now so
it's like it will like businesses will
now push it and say we support this
because it brings like publicity and
sells or whatever whatever you do or
whatever I know me and I know many
people that are gay or whatever many of
us don't give a damn
I didn't even know we had Flags you know
what price two of my Magnum friends at
all and he asked me my opinion on
something I said do you telling me more
about the communities
I said okay bring up lgbtq plus plus
uh blessing can you play one of the
videos I was gonna get their reaction as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform form if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible